big protests this week across the
country against Balenciaga the fashion
fashion house for promoting child
sexualization in its advertisements
which certainly did some of its ads
featured kids holding teddy bears in
bondage gear it's not an accident the
CEO of blenciaga's parent company a man
called Francois enri Pino also owns an
auction house that sold art art that
sexualizes children now one of the
people was disgusted by all of this is
Brittany Aldean she's the wife of the
country singer Jason Aldean and she
joins us tonight Brittany thanks so much
for coming on hi thank you there are I'm
not sure some viewers even know this
there are actual protests against
balenciaga's sexualization of children
correct
yes there are I I for one love fashion I
am super into fashion but I refuse to
represent or wear a brand that has any
affiliation
any affiliation with sexual exploitation
of children or the sexualization of
children it's disgusting and what they
showed us recently in their recent
campaign is pure evil
well it is pure evil I agree with that
and you know fashionable people sneer
and oh you're taking it too seriously
and who cares and no actual child was
hurt why I think it's worth taking
seriously why do you think that it is
it's absolutely worth taking seriously
because every single detail of the photo
shoot was meticulously thought out I've
been on photo shoots before I know that
there are weeks of preparation if not
months this was meticulously thought out
for them to think that it's appropriate
to put children in a situation that
that we have seen much less a campaign
for their brand is disgusting every
single prop every single book every
single teddy bear everything was
meticulously thought out regardless if
they say it was a mistake or not it was
not a mistake they have shown us who
they are it's disgusting it's evil and
the common denominator here is that we
have to stand up we have to fight for
our children this is not political this
is not about religion the common
denominator here is to protect the
children at all costs everybody should
be outraged so nicely put and I and
thank you for saying that about photo
shoots you've been on photo shoots this
so their their claim that oh we had no
idea I mean that's totally observable
correct yeah it's absolutely laughable
yeah
yeah well thank you thank you for doing
this you're not embarrassed and I think
it makes a difference when people are
honest thank you Brady Aldean great to
see you tonight thank you subscribe to
the Fox News YouTube channel to catch
our nightly opens stories that are
changing the world and changing your
life from Tucker Carlson tonight